hey guys it is Monday and we're just a
handful of days out from the biggest
gaming week of the year and that's why
we're here in beautiful San Francisco at
games 4 HQ we are but before we get into
all the e3 bits and pieces let's talk
about what went on today first up it
looks like that gold ps4 that we told
you about on Friday is well and truly a
thing
well that's according to a second league
that's supporting the first leg not only
that it looks like the ps4 is gonna get
a temporary brass car earlier today 20
years ago 64 tweeted out a picture of
the target weekly ad for the week of
June 11th which shows the unannounced
console at a two hundred and fifty
dollar price point Sony have confirmed
the shiny new ps4 is on the way and can
be bought for 250 bucks up until June 17
when it will return to the regular $299
price point as we expected the gold
edition of the ps4 is a slim one
terabyte model according to me ok ok
we'll also have a number of gaming deals
for the week of June 11 including
horizon zero dawn and Mass Effect
Andromeda for 40 bucks each and
battlefield 1 and GTA 5 for just 30
that's not all though CEO of Sony
interactive entertainment Andruw house
told USA Today that Sony will drop the
price on select ps4 systems from 299 to
249 between June 9 and 17 a number of
retailers including Amazon are already
selling the ps4 slim for 250 bucks but
this new price cut will apparently be
more widely available while we're on the
topic of PlayStation it turns out not
everybody loves backwards compatibility
as much as we do or at least according
to a Sony executive you don't want it as
much as you think you just PlayStation
Europe boss Jim Ryan told Time magazine
when we've dabbled with backwards
compatibility I can say it's one of
those features that is much requested
but not actually used much that and I
was at a Gran Turismo event recently
where they had ps1 ps2 ps3 and ps4 games
and the ps1 and the ps2 games they
looked ancient like why would anybody
play this oh boy
in contrast Microsoft has embraced
backwards compatibility on Xbox one the
backwards compatibility program
currently offers over 300 Xbox 360
titles including Red Dead Redemption and
call of duty black ops 2 at e3 2015
playstation boss Shuhei Yoshida said
backward compatibility is hard
I'd say we'll never do it but it's not
an easy thing to do if it was easy we
would have done that big news for
football fans today as the a have
released a lot of information about FIFA
18 home run know this year's entry in
the long-running soccer / football
kicking franchise will arrive on
September 29 for ps4 Xbox one switch ps3
360 and PC but not all the versions of
the game are going to be equal it's been
revealed that the Nintendo switch
version of the game will not run on the
Frostbite engine and that it along with
the ps3 and xbox 360 versions will not
reach a journey mode journey mode is the
single player story mode started in
speed 417 that follows Alex hunter a
rising star in the Premier League Weaver
a teens journey mode is called hunter
returns so it's safe to assume you'll
once again be hitting the pitch in the
cleats of Alex hunter FIFA 18 will also
mark the first time that football legend
Cristiano Ronaldo will grace the cover
FIFA Ultimate Team legends the super
rare cards based on players of the past
that were exclusive to Xbox has been
rebranded as icons and will now come to
ps4 and PC finally there's several
different versions of the game available
for you to pre-order if that's something
you want to do and you preorder the
Ronaldo or icon Edition you'll get three
days of early access to the game ahead
of release while EA and Origen access
members on PC and Xbox one will get
Aitken our trial starting September 21st
the Ronaldo and Icahn editions will also
get you some extra goodies including a
five-match Ronaldo fut lone jumbo
premium gold packs and special edition
fut kids
oh that is everything we've got for you
today but do you let us know in that
comment section what you cared about
today and you can grab the game spot now
app on iOS and Android to get the top
ten news stories of the day delivered
straight to your phone that's it from us
today but join us again tomorrow for
much more news